I got a few questions I want to talk to
you about and I want to see how you
process this it's a conversation we're
having about morality and law and prayer
and religion and why do oppressive
governments fear opposing faith in
religion and they kind of want to get
rid of it specifically when you think
about what Ma Stalin KL Marx what they
believed in they got to get people to
believe in God less and it sounds like
we're kind of going in that direction in
certain places then we pulled up some
weird data what country praise the most
what countries go to church the most
what age praise the most and why and we
pulled up a scale like what is really
the difference between different
religions when it comes on to certain
morals and values same-sex marriage
change today we Catholic I don't know if
you saw what the pope said killing
adultery stealing sex change what are
some similarities between Christianity
Islam Buddhism Judaism Hinduism what is
it and where does morality come from and
how it differs from law we're going to
talk about that today morality where
does morality come from if I was to ask
you right now where does morality come
from what would you say would you say
well I was just born a moral person you
think you and I are born moral do you do
certain things or not do certain things
because you're just so moral above and
beyond everybody else they say morality
comes from three different places and
every one of them makes an argument for
whatever it is let's entertain all three
of them one is divine it comes from God
it comes from a manual and then we learn
about it so we stop killing each other
or killing friends or you know adultery
with somebody else's wife and he's
married and you or vice versa she's
married you go after the husband or for
same-sex marriage according to Quran you
know how they are not for it not
accepted Christianity not accepted not
addressed in scripture for Buddhism and
not accepted in Judaism and diverse
perspective in Hinduism and adultery and
stealing not accepted not accepted not
accepted not accepted sex change not
addressed they didn't talk about in the
Bible not addressed not addressed not
addressed not addressed you talk about
these things okay one area of morality
maybe comes from Divine Church religion
uh some say no no it's it's it's based
on a social contract that we have Neil
degrass Tyson kind of talked about this
say we as the populist have a social
contract to do what's right for the
other person and you are liable as a
social contract to get the vaccine to
you know and that that was the pitch
wait a minute what I never signed this
social contract and and the other one is
individual reason like stoicism you know
what's right you feel it in your
conscious and that's where morality
comes from but does it now if you're an
atheist and maybe you're morally sound
but you don't believe in God but you
know you're like well i' I've been like
this my entire life but maybe your
parents taught you the right morals and
values and maybe they were faith-based
and if they weren't faith-based maybe
their parents were but eventually in the
lineage somebody you know lived a
morally right life well that's what laws
are for laws are different than moral
laws you just follow cuz you don't want
to go to jail you don't want to pay fine
you don't want to do certain things you
don't want to get sued those are laws
morality I just don't think this is the
right thing to do having said that when
you think about this we go in the
direction of different religions and
what they're doing and we think about
prayer what they're taking out so having
said that let me tell you a couple
things that different people have said
in the past Thomas Jefferson said the
two enemies of the people are criminals
and the government so let us tie the
second down with the chains of the
Constitution so the second will not
become the legalized version of the
first which is criminals and what if
government starts recruiting criminals
and they work together against you by
the way this happen some people may be
watching this in different countries
saying that's what's going on in Mexico
right now that's what's going on XYZ
right now some of that may going on in
America right now that's the fear right
watch this Carl Mars author of The
Communist Manifesto said communism
begins when atheism begins communism
begins when atheism begins why do you
need people to stop believing in a
higher law so their God is replaced with
the government oh the government's my
God and a ruler or president becomes my
God okay maybe this guy just wrote a
book he didn't know what he was talking
how about ma here's what ma said during
the cultural revolution religion became
a target of Ma's campaign to eliminate
the four olds four olds old things old
ideas old customs and old habits and
replace it with ma to new thing I am who
you follow and I rule over you not God
not this to the point where all religion
activities were banned and religious
Personnel were persecuted parliamentary
Red Guard attacked or destroyed many
temples shrines churches and mosques and
some were abandoned closed or
confiscated Chinese people who wanted to
maintain their faith practice in secret
and even today G in 2013 when you think
about what he said the government banned
evangelization online tighten controls
over Christian activities outside of
register ven and shut down churches that
refuse to register authorities also
arrested prominent church leaders and
some Christian reportedly have held in
camps Christianity in China is governed
by several sets of rules so if you want
to practice Christianity in China you
got to do it underground and Stalin he
argued the new socialist man was an
atheist one free of the religious chains
that had helped to bind him to class
oppression here's a guy talking about
class oppression that took everything
away from everybody and he became the
powerful one it's interesting how they
SP on it he closed churches synagogues
and mosques and ordered the killing and
imprisonment of thousands of religious
leaders in an effort to eliminate even
the concept of God so it didn't matter
what the religion was whether you were a
Christian a Jew or a Muslim got to get
rid of these why he saw this as a way of
getting rid of a past that was holding
people back and marching towards the
future of Science and progress called
the Stalin's holy war which was religion
and a Godless 5-year plan launched in
1928 gave local cells of anti-religious
organizations Le of militant atheist
Neals to the establish religion and by
the way keep in mind I'm coming from a
place of I'm a faith guy faith is risky
right you you don't necessarily know
what's going to happen after we die
there's a risk we're taking whether you
believe in God or not if you don't
believe there's a risk if you do believe
there's a risk I'm not coming from a
place of certainty where I am coming
from a place of certainty is if we
eliminate Faith or the opportunity for
people to have a different religion you
have to replace that with somebody
coming out with the morality and and
then we start questioning everything
what makes you think it's immoral for
somebody to cut off and chop off their
private parts and transition who says
it's immoral who are you to say it's
immoral well my religion does well your
religion you believe in religion you're
that naive you're going to take your
morality based on a book written by
however many people 2,000 years ago and
it's been translated so many times what
makes you think it was written about
this what makes oh maybe they're right
so you know what I will take my morality
from this governor in California or from
this president from Delaware and maybe
that's what I need to do and and yeah
I'm really starting to question this
concept of morality wow I never thought
about this before and then that's the
whole game and then they'll introduce
yeah this is okay yeah this is okay yeah
this is okay no it's not okay and if
you're somebody that's single watching
is like I don't know where the hell
Pat's coming for I thought this we're
going to talk about this and what is
this all about but if you're married
with kids you're sitting there saying
this is a worry of mine and a concern of
mine what's been eliminated for this to
become normal prayer from school so
where daily prayer is most common
Nigeria according to Statia 95% of the
time Iran 87% then it's India then it's
Brazil then it's us right now in Iran
99.4% of the people there are Muslims
with the religion in America is diverse
right remember there's also this element
of the government using the religion to
force you to do something that's not
what we're talking about here we're not
talking about some countries that rule
their people with God said this and
guilt and all this other stuff listen go
practice your church but why are some of
these totalitarian oppressive places
trying to eliminate opposing ideas of
Faith what if people believe in a God
that something is possible and I can do
this I can overcome this are those types
of people tough to control are those
types of people enemies of the state are
those types of people enemies of a
controlling oppressive state of course
they are we don't need people to have
faith what happens if we have people
that have faith you believe the future
looks right that's not a good thing we
should get people to believe future is
bad and ugly and nasty
oh my god control you do what we do
we're here to protect you and morality
and everything I'm telling you is you've
seen the movies and you seen in some
countries we've read read about in
history book could it happen in York
will never happen in America why not we
get rid of morality and our like yeah
who cares that's the GU who cares his
wife yeah who cares not it's a kid I
can't marry you this yeah this 42y old
man loves this 13year old girl so
morality moral yeah but Bible is do you
see how weird this gets slippery and
this is all a byproduct in my opinion of
tolerant Christians who are sitting
there and thinking yeah maybe they're
right maybe tolerant Catholics and maybe
tolerant this it's a slippery slope if
you're a parent this is something again
I'm thinking about this so we look at
Stacks weekly worship attendance is most
where life is the shortest makes sense
again keep in mind these are all
questions that I want you to process and
think about right because I'm I'm kind
of going through it with you I I can
show you a lot of data when you look at
data here's what you'll notice countries
where life expectancy is the lowest
people pray the most countries where
life expectancy is the highest people
pray the least countries where are the
wealthiest they pray the least for
example if I were to look at what
countries you know pray the most
Afghanistan Nigeria Sagal Chad Iran
these guys pray a lot if I say countries
that pray the least Norway Switzerland
Ireland Austria Germany right and us
even though you know we have one of the
higher life expectancies in the world we
pray 53% of us pray I can give you this
data and you know all this other stuff
but I want I want to make I want to make
the one point here and I want you to
really think about this here
what is better for society what is
better for you your kids your family
where you live no matter what part of
the country or the world you're living
in is it better for the people to fear
God Is it better for people to fear
their government or is it better for
people to fear being socially ostracized
so let's kind of unpack that those three
questions for you and you get to answer
this question for yourself if people
fear God based on certain set of values
and principles because they want favor
from God and they want Grace from God
will they be a better net positive to
society and by the way I'm not talking
about you know fanatical where you know
the whole the the church and state
separation between some governments want
you to only believe in their Church
trust me I lived in Iran and they use
their religion as a fear they impose on
their people that's not what I'm talking
about I'm talking about America you want
to be Christian go ahead Scientology go
ahead LDS go ahead atheist go ahead
agnostic go ahead that that whole
concept in America is we're talking
about but let's go to it is it better
for when when the populace fears God or
is it better when we fear the government
oh my god oh I fear the president oh
fear fear the government Governor
California what if fear you don't say
anything a fear of socially hate don't
say anything what if we get canceled
what's my real opinion on the
transgender and all that what's my real
opinion on this oh my God they're not
going to be accepting me I'm not going
to be able to go to that party what's
better for society I'm sorry what what
is better for society if if I have to
sit there and fear my kids going to
school and praying to a God yeah we
don't believe in God I don't care Prayer
by itself is strong positive affirmation
so imagine what a prayer is really all
about thank you God for this great life
you've given me well I don't really have
a great life I have an average life can
you find something to be grateful for I
can thank you God the fact that my
mother is still alive thank you that
you've given 32 years of my dad in my
life I have friends that don't have a
father in life thank you that I know
both my mom and my dad thank you for
keeping me healthy and thank you for
being able to go to the school and learn
a few things is that that scary to start
the day being grateful and thankful does
that make the relationship of the kids
with the parents better does that make
the relationship with the kids and their
peers better do they become a better
Society if they are thankful and
grateful do you see where I'm going with
this for me I'm a little bit concerned
about the direction we're going with
with the Pope coming out and saying ah
it's okay it's okay another tolerant you
know Christian figure powerful figure
there's nobody more powerful than a
Catholic Church Pope going out there
saying yeah we accepting that's totally
fine it's going to be okay it's not a
big deal we're all Sinners you know
these guys just sin in a different way
yeah I don't know I don't know about
that to so we we're no longer following
this this this book called The Bible Mr
Pope you know was written and you for
many many years the reason why you're a
pope is because somebody back in the
days was teaching out of this Bible and
the Catholic Church got bigger and we
know the history of the Catholic church
and what happened and what's oh yeah but
let's do this yeah I don't know I have a
hard time with this if there's any I
think a country where the populace fears
God more than they fear their government
these people cannot be controlled and
they inject more hope and and confidence
into the people than Society where
people fear God or social osteri oh my
God what if I get Jud I don't know about
that so for you if you're watching and
what can I do about it challenge impose
say I'm not afraid I believe in God I
think everything's going to be okay
we're going to pray we are going to be
grateful have that conversation at the
end of the day nobody knows 100% what's
going on the only thing is what Society
has proven better results when we're
asking this basic question on a podcast
why do Muslims move to Christian Nation
like America but why do Christian people
and Jews not move to Muslim Nation
ations why because maybe America economy
tolerance allowing others to coexist we
can maybe what is that is there
something good about that or no you have
to understand these are some questions
that people are asking and these are
valid questions you may agree or
disagree with it that's where the debate
starts and that's where the conversation
begins and that is something we at Value
tment and pbd podcast are very
comfortable with because we need more of
it today if you got value added this
video I got two videos I want you to
think about watching one of them is the
angest people in the world and by the
way I'm my background is number three on
this list the other one is a Muslim
versus Christian debate that we had
where millions of people worldwide
watched if you've never seen it click
here to watch that this one is a debate
it it gets heated you're going to get
angry one way or the other but it's
discourse something we need more of in
the world today take care everybody
bye-bye